i want to bring on my friend poppy lou
who's been doing some some great work
with
reproductive justice she's an actor and
an activist please welcome poppy hey
papi
hi so good of you to take some time out
from your
schedule as a smash hit sitcom star
yeah the cult classic sunny side right
up there with
donnie darko it really is the donnie
darko of sitcoms
you know that's the only way to describe
it
and you are the jake gyllenhaal of
indie comedy is what everyone says i
keep saying that to deadline they keep
sending me the same cease and desist
thank you for being here i wanted to
talk to you because you're doing
something cool
with with this time and uh maybe you
could tell us a little bit about some of
your your activism work you probably
explain it a little bit better
than i can but it's around reproductive
justice which is
a very important issue right now and is
getting even more
serious because of our recent supreme
court
whoopsie daisies yeah um so i
serve on the board of a really
incredible organization
called sister song um sisters and women
of color reproductive justice collective
and it is entirely led by black
indigenous
latinx and asian pacific islander women
of color and queer trans people of color
um with the idea that like we need to be
centering
the most marginalized communities first
if we're trying to
create the liberated world that we are
dreaming of
and the reason why it's reproductive
justice is because
kind of prior to this the movement
around like abortion was very much like
like a white second wave feminist
like um framework of it in terms of
pro-choice and anti-choice
um that's how like abortion was talked
about and that was sort of like the
extent of the conversation
about like body autonomy and rights but
um the idea here is that you know you
don't really have
choice actually if you don't have access
you know you don't have choice if you're
facing state violence you don't face
you don't have choice if you're
undocumented um
and you can't like and you're fearing
deportation you don't have choice if
like
you know you're incarcerated so this
is more about access it's about meeting
communities and people where they're at
um and it's really shifting the
conversation
into a way that's looking more
holistically at um
sister songs does it really great
they're like it's about people's
rights that have children if they want
to not have children if they don't want
to
and to raise their families in safe and
sustainable environments
that's the organization they're the best
they're so great more recently during
quarantine
i started a campaign within sister song
called asians for black births which is
in support of the work that
deputy director leah jones um at sister
song is doing
that's called the birth justice care
fund which is just like providing direct
funds for right now like um primarily
black mamas and caregivers in georgia
um just support around birth postpartum
labor doula needs like midwives etc
and so this campaign asians for black
births
is like really rallying my asian
american and asian pacific islander
communities
to be supporting this work um and it's
not just a fundraiser we're hoping that
like we're using this to like
actually kind of share information with
asian american communities
who like historically have been very
complicit with whiteness have really not
examined their own
proximity to whiteness um have like not
always shown solidarity with black and
brown communities
um and like really asking ourselves
during this moment to be like we need to
look at
our own histories and our own
complicities to understand how we show
up as like
migrants at like in this moment in time
okay so as far as the the organization
goes
it's it's helping people with with
actual resources or some of the money is
going towards
sometimes just supporting some of these
yeah
so the birth choices care fund is direct
monetary support for people that are
giving birth
um but sister's song at large they do
all sorts of things
um including uh court cases
well you're doing really great work and
you're honestly making us
look bad for not doing the same so
people want to support
sister song and the work you're doing
which you've already raised
a lot of money where can people find you
if they want to
they want to help out for asians for
black birth you can go to
asians for black births on instagram and
then there's a link that goes to the
gofundme and yeah learn more about
sister song they're on instagram
at sister song underscore woc um
and sisterzone.net so go there
until everything we're there okay thank
you so much for talking with us
and and educating us and letting us know
what we can do to help because there's
obviously so many things out there that
just to narrow it down is great
thank you love you too thank you so much
good seeing you poppy lou everyone the
organization is sister song